Korea is a highly competitive workplace
it's super competitive for students you
have to have perfect grades the perfect
looks everyone there talks about beauty
constantly and they tell you straight to
your face that you're ugly or that you
should get plastic surgery that's why
people feel like it's a good career move
to get plastic surgery what we're doing
today is sort of recreating this
practice that's very common in Korea but
in a way that's not permanent really a
sort of sliding doors potential second
reality if I had chosen to alter the way
I look so I am a quarter Korean I lived
in the South of South Korea in a city
called Daegu for a year and I saw a lot
of [ __ ] when I was there all of the
subways are like plastered with banner
ads that say you should get plastic
surgery I actually had an article and I
wrote about on BuzzFeed that also went
viral on the Daily Mail where the
headline was literally too fat too tall
and too dark to be beautiful in South
Korea and that's honestly how I felt
when I was a kid I felt like my eyes
were small because I didn't have double
eyelids I had a couple of relatives like
suggest that like I get a double eyelid
surgery in some ways I think about it
I'm like that's that's messed up in
other ways it was like an act of concern
and love to grow up in society and a
culture that's very frank about the way
you look changes the way you perceive
your personal relationship with beauty
first time I went to Korea all of my
mom's friends there looked at me right
when I got and they said well you know
your son could get the eye surgery and a
nose job and get his face smaller and
you know I had a lot of insecurities
about that I thought oh maybe it's
because I am ugly maybe it's because
they want me to look a certain way fast
forward to now when my mom - the same
friends shows videos of me and they all
say oh your son is so handsome oh
there's nothing wrong with his face do
you want the [ __ ] they change their
minds because I'm successful now so if
you think about it a lot of Koreans
don't necessarily say you will look
better because you're white looking
they're thinking you can survive and you
succeed more if you change certain
things because that is
what's happening society I'm really
terrified of what this surgeon is gonna
say to me because I feel like he's going
to be like my worst critic ever I've
worked so hard to feel okay with my body
and to feel like a deaf commercial
inside and I know this man is going to
tell me that I'm so ugly and I'm
terrified I was very nice to meet you
doctor nice to meet you I would love to
see what I think is sort of the standard
for like a hot young Korean guy I'd love
to know what I could do to make my face
as close to the mainstream beauty ideal
currently in Korea okay when you go
ahead and put your hair behind your ears
a little bit oh here we go here we go
y'all gonna be fine no problem that may
be nerves [ __ ] let's have you turn to me
a little bit here's my potato face y'all
there is sort of a stereotypical Korean
beauty standard that people try to
adhere to there's a big focus on Beauty
around the eyes they're looking for it
was that a little bit sharp and pointed
at the end and finally they're looking
for a facial shape which is more v-line
and kind of has a slimmer look so those
I'd say would be the most common facial
aesthetic procedures this is very
intimate I just made it weird sorry yeah
let's not make this weird they're there
okay overall very good looking face
pretty girl I'd say your face looks very
nice
great skin good looking guy you've good
facial features starting sorta from the
top down think your brows look very good
I think for your eyes very common to get
the typical
Asian double eyelid yeah I think your
distance between your brow and your
eyelash looks pretty normal and healthy
so I think a standard double eyelid
would look nice I lived I think double
eyelid be reasonable maybe just make the
eyes look a little bit bigger and your
distance between your eyebrows and your
lash line here a little bit on the
shorter side went from there I would say
your nose and the front view looks a
little bit wide to me and so I think
narrowing would also give you a nice
rest at it for the rhinoplasty
there'd be two key things I would do one
would be to shave down that hump at the
top and the second would be to work on
that typically for the cheeks are there
some fat grafting or even a cheek
implant if you want to have a little bit
more profile I would recommend
considering some fat grafting which is
to move a little bit of fat from other
parts your body and put it into your
cheeks to make the cheeks a little bit
softer looking for the lower part of
your face I think down here you do have
a little bit of a t tissue in this area
a comment for a lot of people also and
so I think that one thing you consider
would be there take a little bit of
buccal fat which is to make a small
incision on the inside of the cheek and
finally for your jaw here overall face
shape is a little bit more on the round
very typically a lot of women in Korea
are looking for something that's a
little bit more v-line a combination of
Botox and this to kind of shrink that
muscle as well as potentially shaving
down this jaw a little bit I think we
kind of give you a little bit more of a
v-shape that wasn't as scary as I
thought it would be it seems like a lot
of the changes would be subtle it was a
long list of procedures to get me to
point B I'm glad to know that my face is
mostly great like I thought it would be
like let's just do everything but it is
kind of scary for me to think that I
might see like a better version of
myself so we'll see
got to get rid of this neck fat y'all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
holy [ __ ] I'm scared I'm mainly worried
that I'm gonna like it am I gonna look
at it while it changes oh [ __ ] okay wait
wait don't do I'm really nervous now is
something about it it's so derpy thick
it definitely doesn't look like me it
looks like an evil doctor doppelganger
so I see how they gave me double eyelids
but I'm surprised at how much I don't
like them I like the defined jawline it
could probably achieve that by like
losing a couple pounds yeah I'm not a
huge fan of the eyes maybe it's just the
Photoshop but I just looked dead I look
dead inside and
huh it's kind of weird cuz it looks
vaguely like me but like not really it's
not as drastic as I thought it was gonna
be which is a little bit scary like the
subtlety of it is like no one would
really know that I had plastic surgery
to be honest I thought I'd be hotter and
now that I'm not that hot it's like I
don't really want to risk going under
the knife to be 5% more hot 5% more aw
it's not worth it like 25% [ __ ] yeah but
like you know what would improve this is
just like if I had abs you know that
would be better holy [ __ ] oh my god my
jaw is much smaller the nose is thinner
he's got a cute little face he looks
good it doesn't look bad he's the way
nicer version of me I think in terms of
like the face my biggest takeaway is
that uncomfortable with looking at this
now without feeling shitty by myself
but I also am NOT looking at this and
thinking that I'm like more beautiful
when than this picture it's nice to see
that this is a somewhat natural option
that I don't think people would look at
and think I looked like a freak or weird
so hopefully like if someone feels like
this will make them more confident and
they get it if they're still
recognizable as a person I don't see the
problem with it maybe the one thing
that's a little problematic is we have
to think as koreans if we are just ever
so slightly changing the way we think we
should look I don't think that we should
necessary think this looks better than
this right and I think that's what a lot
of people are currently suffering from
is this idea that I have to look more
this way to be accepted I don't think
I'd want to adhere to a trend and then
not be able to go back on it like you
can even remove a tattoo you can't
remove a nose job when I was in Korea I
thought at some point that if I got more
plastic surgery I could maybe look more
Korean and fit in but now that I'm
seeing what the plastic surgery would be
I'm realizing that the parts of me that
don't fit in are the parts that make me
unique I think what it really comes down
to is we just need more of like this
right we just need more of our own
natural faces and media and not to like
[ __ ] on or dis on people who get plastic
surgery as Asians we just need to
diversify what we're seeing and it's not
saying that this is bad it's just saying
that only seeing this is bad
everybody deserves to feel okay about
who they are I guess I just like my face
better than I thought
I don't need that to feel good about
myself or to make other people feel good
about how they look so I'm gonna keep my
little eyes and my big nose in my big
face
it's what my momma gave me and she's hot
ah why you said why you cry right cry
sexy Ashley don't cry
[Music]